and i'm going to play some cool intro
music
because i paid for it so why not some
dramatic intro music for the into the
impossible podcast
simultaneously broadcast live on
uh on clubhouse and then this will
appear later on so if you missed it on
clubhouse don't worry
although i don't know that would violate
the bounds of space and time for that to
occur
uh you can see me okay peter i can see
you great man
all right my apologies okay so here we
go
welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast
into the impossible podcast is a
production of the arthur c clarke center
for human imagination at the university
of california san diego
where i am the chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics
and i talk to people uh in all different
capacities from billionaires
brainiacs and uh thought leaders and
today i'm speaking to
someone who's all three of those a
billionaire
i don't know not yet right peter you say
the first billion's the hardest right
yeah i think i'd rather be the first and
the second or the third
so uh peter vergosian is uh as a
professor at portland state university
we're going to get into
aspects of academia but this is meant to
be a conversation
that i've long wanted to have and that
involves
the difficulties and challenges
presented
when discussing difficult sensitive
thought-provoking ideas and concepts but
wanting to do so
with comity and maybe some comedy too
uh and peter exemplifies that uh and is
is really um kind of a rare breed and
someone who seeks to achieve
not agreement but clarity and i think
that's a rare trait so peter thank you
so much for joining us
on the into the impossible podcast
thanks for having me on i appreciate it
and
i'm eager to kind of test some my ideas
as a as uh my unlettered opinions
in physics if i can uh and i was hoping
maybe we could start
that way yeah okay we're i'm happy to do
that as
uh and and just to remind folks that uh
we will take questions from the
clubhouse stage later on in the podcast
after we
get our host prerogatives we're kind of
dual hosting this particular episode
uh but yes i'm happy if you want to
start off i am more than happy to do it
and otherwise
i will uh we will stay tuned though
because we will do what's called live
action role playing uh using astronomy
and this i don't know if you can see
peter uh this is a finger puppet of
galileo galilei
the very first astronomical observer in
human history some say the father
of all of science some say the father of
relativity
but he's also the father of a very
important project to me which i'm going
to find
called the dialogues the dialogues
on the two chief world systems
and we're going to talk about that i
hope and maybe do some live action role
playing
excellent where i i take the role of
galileo and you become the inquisitor
in the catholic church okay but for now
you're already
okay so i i've decided that i want to
jump to that i love that
i just absolutely love that you want to
do that first is that okay
yeah let's do it so um i'm fascinated by
galileo for many reasons
he was a brilliant person he was a very
flawed person
he was a complex individual like we all
are
he was one of the best and first popular
science writers
he had venal ambitions he had
several mistresses and illegitimate
children to support
and and he's famous for constructing
many many things that we take for
granted
perhaps not really knowing that it's
attributed to him
and one of which i want to start off
reading to you and ask you if this
resonates with you it's something that
you've written about
it's a statement made in the in the book
uh the dialogue
by the way this book does not exist in
audio form
yet i'm recording the first ever
audiobook of galileo galilei
along with a very very famous scientist
by the name of carlo rovelli
who wrote seven brief lectures on
physics he's an amazing
person so we're reading these voices
back and forth and stay tuned for more
information you can see my website
i should have that audio book already
listed anyway here's a sentence
kind of in the middle of galileo in the
middle of the dialogue
he says the following he says about
intellectuals
he says this vain presumption of
understanding
everything can have no other basis than
never understanding anything for anyone
who had experienced
just once the perfect knowledge of one
single thing and had truly tasted how
knowledge is accomplished
he would recognize that of the infinity
of other truths he understands
nothing and this to me i want to try it
on you is kind of reminiscent of what
you guys call the dunning-kruger effect
the sort of steepness of the learning
curve and i submit
that galileo had extreme brilliance and
genius in physics
but of course his genius did not extend
to the political realm
and in sort of this role-playing
adventure i want to uh
perhaps uh investigate that someone how
someone can be so intellectual in one
realm
but so clueless about human nature and
in so
writing the the dialogues he tried to
have an impossible conversation
one that you are intimately familiar
with involving
a revolution on the understanding of the
earth and his position
in the universe which was basically the
solar system
galileo famously believed that the earth
went around the sun and not the other
way around
but i submit to you you're a brilliant
person peter can you prove to me
as the pope that the earth let's say now
for a second you be galileo
that the earth is in motion can you
prove it to me do you know how we prove
it
yeah so so i'm just going to jump into
the role play
okay yeah so what evidence would satisfy
you that that's the case
like what would that have to look like
that i show you
so it would have to be evidence that is
uh that is
accessible it shouldn't require some
something beyond
humanity's ability to collect it should
be
interpretable it should be uh the
evidence should be
dispositive in other words it should be
necessary evidence and
sufficient evidence it shouldn't be um
necessarily
um uh circumstantial i would say okay
those are all pieces of evidence that i
would require
uh but the main point is evidence uh in
some sense
uh although we now and you talk about a
lot in your book this confirmation
that wasn't really a concept that
existed back then uh not that i'm saying
we have to be beholden to that framework
but nevertheless i submit that uh i
don't even think in modern physics
that um that disconfirmation is a
necessary part
of the intellectual uh refutation or
proof of a scientific uh theories
and it might not be but in the context
of what you've asked me to do we're
talking about the pope's belief system
right
yeah so right starting off with a
disconfirmation question is the best way
to elicit
whether or not he's genuinely willing to
revise his belief on the basis of
evidence
so back to the role play so just so that
we're clear
so that if i can give you evidence that
satisfies
all three criteria you would be able to
change your mind
you would change your mind
yes i would certainly change my mind
okay
so if you're willing to change your mind
on that
then you're in in a very real sense
you're beholden to the evidence is that
right
yes i am but you should also note that i
believe nothing is beyond god's ability
even the uh even the simulation
of effects that would prove your
hypothesis correct in other words
there's nothing god can't do including
make it appear that the earth is moving
when in fact it's stationary
well that definitely moves the bar a
little bit
so i guess i didn't say it would be fair
right so i guess my concern then is if i
brought up
a piece of evidence and you were to say
that to me that
that's just an artifact of how god wants
you to see things
and you'd use that to retain your world
view
what what would you suggest that i do in
that case
well first i would ask you um do you
believe it's true that god can make it
appear
that the earth is in motion when in fact
it's stationary
i don't think that the question has
bearing in the context of
our conversation i think what has
bearing is that we can
both admit if we can what would
constitute
as you said uh necessary and sufficient
evidence for that and if we can agree
upon that
then it seems to me the burden is upon
me to show you that evidence right
yeah i would say i would stipulate that
sure okay
so admittedly at that time also lens
technology is very crude
but and and the there's some fascinating
stuff about what happened when people
actually did look through telescopes but
um you know victorine just
parenthetically has a famous uh
uh quotation what would the earth look
like
what would how would things be different
if the
the sun rotated around the earth like it
wouldn't look any different than it does
now right
so what about optics
right so so so again i understand that
we're
this is uh going back we're in time but
what about
optics if i can present you with um
um admittedly crude and fuzzy but images
from far away
would that sway you yeah i would i would
do that i would even put my eye on
yeah i would even put my eye on the
telescope if you would uh
i'm not yes i would certainly okay
well then then you are indeed you you
are indeed a man
uh whose views i come to respect because
you're willing to revise your beliefs
so what i just did there is i alter
casted him so
oh and by the way peter we we here in
the vatican
we here in the vatican have a very
advanced even to this day in 2021
a very advanced astronomical observatory
with a four meter diameter telescope
uh that is used not to make observations
of angels and so forth we actually do
serious scientific research with the
vatican observatory
by the way peter is there any way to
turn to make uh
are you are you hardwired in on internet
on ethernet it's
your video is very grainy i don't know
if mine is i'm on your audio is fine
i'm on dsl um i'm in the middle of
nowhere right now
i do want me to do something else uh
okay
is your is your phone or are there any
other devices using the wi-fi too
uh only my phone that's it i'm in a very
low-tech
place okay
okay that's fine um i know how you guys
do things in the northwest
over here um so yeah so getting back yes
i will certainly not
yeah not only use a telescope i will
fund the
construction of a telescope because even
in the inquisition i had
teams of scientists working for me and
the vatican
uh staff uh the best scientist of our
time
to do what
so they so they were in in investigating
natural phenomena
that would bolster the majesty and
extravagance of the creator's abilities
and did they start from the conclusion
that they weren't sure
what if the earth revolved around the
sun or what what conclu
do they have a starting conclusion
i think they had a starting point which
is that uh in
the pre context of monotheism that the
phenomena that we witness in the natural
world
are governed by natural laws themselves
established by the creator
some for our benefit and and the
and these laws are not governed by other
gods so we believe in a monotheistic god
therefore we don't believe in the god of
thunder and the god of lightning
and we believe in one unified god who
set the laws of nation
and would there ever be any evidence
that could cause you
to challenge that belief or lower your
confidence in that
um i if there was a testable prediction
uh it's hard for me actually peter to
argue this because it's actually
not true in the jewish uh bible
right that the earth is the center of
the universe but uh but
arguing as my christian brothers and
sisters would argue uh uh
it seems that the evidence was you know
from the book of joshua
and you know once or twice um you know
my personal belief
is that it didn't uh it did not
obviously
uh prove that the earth or the bible
does not state explicitly that the earth
is the center of the universe
but from the vatican's perspective we i
would
i would accept it insofar as it does not
limit god's ability
but i would be very cautious to you
peter galileo because
um you're upsetting an entire uh uh
entire world view right so you're
playing with fire that
that you would come to question the
veracity of
the of the the of the bible so so in
other words the stakes are very high in
this conversation
yeah so i think that's part of the
problem i don't think he would answer
that
i don't think that would be his response
i think he'd just say no
because he was also remember in
aristotle in book eight of the physics
in book 12 in the metaphysics he's very
specific about an immortal
uh unchanging being and and you know
they it comes
plato's times talks about this very
explicitly about the globes and the
heavens although it's not specifically
to the
earth revolving on the sun but i don't
think he admit that there's
any evidence that could ever um cause
him to revise his god belief
yeah i would say that's right yeah so if
i say that
what would you say next i mean the dalai
lama has you know said
if the claims of buddhism can't
contradict the claims of science he'll
defer to the claims of science which is
really an extraordinary claim for a
religious leader
but i think that in those cases if you
if you can
in a context of a conversation like that
that it's almost an impossible
conversation
the key is to figure out what the
disconfirmation
are so if people can agree upon those
then they can move forward
the difficult thing is that he was
living absent
the technology you know the
lens technology for example to make that
case in any convincing way
so you're really let me turn it around
on you so i agree 100
yeah but i think galileo actually the
conclusion of this book
uh it's not written with the catchy
title like your books are
this book the original title was not the
dialogue on the two world systems
the pope forced galileo to change the
title to this title
from its original title peter its
original title was not as catchy as how
to have impossible conversations or
losing the nobel prize
the original title was on the flux and
reflux
of tides and the earth's oceans rivers
and ferns now i know you're up in the
land of ferns but it's a different kind
of fern
uh apparently it's a type of waterway
that they had over there in italy
but the point being galileo his
evidence the strongest piece of evidence
was that the tides on the earth
are governed by the combined sloshing of
the earth's
oceans as the earth rotates on its axis
and revolves around the sun so in other
words this
here's some some whiskey here so as it's
rotating around it's kind of sloshing
around
and you see it's sloshing maybe in the
camera so that was according to galileo
the proof of this uh of the earth's
fundamental
proof that the earth was in motion
around the sun which is what his thesis
was right
yeah you know you as galileo what if i
say that to you
well you'd have to be able to rule out
alternative yeah it was not only false
yeah i mean it's funny it just it uh
right not to drive
even at that time go ahead
brian no no go ahead not to drag it what
what did you say not to
drag the car yeah can you hear me into
it yeah not to drag the conversation
into the gutter i was thinking
about bill o'reilly's argument for the
existence of god tides
go in tides go out so that phenomena can
be
interpreted any one of a number of ways
and you have to rule out alternative
hypotheses for those right
right right and don't forget he's a
master of spin so be careful correct
correct but i think that the bill
o'reilly knows everything there is to
know about
i think in the context of these
conversations the conversation we're
having now
what's most important is to establish
criteria
right from the beginning of the
conversation so what would it take for
you to
believe so you don't present your
evidence because
there's a almost a wired desire for
people to
want to cling to existing beliefs right
so belief revision is not a moral virtue
so you have to ask them to provide their
disconfirmation criteria and i realize
that that's a historical
and then if you can agree upon that then
that's how to move forward
the problem is i think in this context
there really is no
excuse me disconfirmation criteria
because the the beliefs aren't formed in
the basis of evidence
right so they'll they'll use evidence to
budget
beliefs that they already have and so
those things are almost always
sociological psychological moral but not
epistemological or scientific
so that brings us you know 400 years to
the future to now
and um and we're still having these
kinds of conversations
in some sense that are impossible in
that in the scientific
realm people believe things uh for which
there's no
uh there's no evidence currently on an
observational front
and there are some that say it's even
even if i stipulate to you peter let's
say you believe in the string theory
multiverse
of our friend lawrence krauss you
believe that there is a string theory
multiverse
uh that not only can't be uh falsified
it also there's there's there's no
prospect to eventually even
prove it in other words the existence of
a multiverse uh
can admit the uh the existence of an
infinite number
of universes in which i'm in portland
state and you're at ucsd
and so i wonder you know in this in this
context
how do you handle things that's a
preferred universe yeah
the problem is yeah victor stinger was a
friend an um
informal mentor of mine and god in the
multiverse addresses that
kraus addresses also mutual friend of
ours kraus addresses that as well
it's it's the same thing as anything
else there's no special pleading uh you
know brian greene would say geez it
could be
a waste of a lot of good math why
why would you believe it if it's not
falsifiable there's no evidence for it
um it certainly makes an elegant theory
but on what basis do you believe it
right well and this of course is true
from galileo's time to today
well i also think that's a kind of a
superstition
that i see in academic philosophy and
elsewhere
the idea that there has to be some kind
of a unified field theory
the idea that the realm of the very
small and the very large have to be
somehow connected um you know it's
heisenberg's odinning the virklish
maybe there is no ordering of reality
maybe there's just
um maybe there's just there's just is
and i think a lot of people are
hoodwinked both by the language
you know we mentioned before in a very
brief conversation we had about the
infinite regress which i also think is a
kind of academic superstition
so i think people are hoodwinked by
concepts that have been around for a
long time
yeah and that dovetails nicely with
another concept of someone you bring up
in the book carl sagan
another sock puppet here for those that
will be watching on youtube
uh the the notion of you know the amount
of
space in the universe that kind of uh
uh is allied in concept with the fermi
paradox which we can talk about
but this this notion that if there is no
life
it's an awful waste of space but there's
no obligation
for us not to waste space and uh there's
no there's no saying that there has to
be necessarily a purpose i actually had
this conversation with sean carroll
who's an eminent physicist at caltech
when he was on the podcast and i said
he has a famous lecture you know why god
is not
a good theory if he doesn't say that
equivocally you can rule out the
existence of god although he is a
what he calls a poetic naturalist we can
talk about materialism and naturalism
and secularism later but
but he basically says because of the
existence of a simpler
universe than the one that we exist in
and because of the
parsimonious nature of an omnipotent
being
you know the existence of the hubble
deep field with trillions of galaxies
you know possibly in our universe that
led to the notion there are trillions of
galaxies in just our observable universe
that's a huge waste of space in other
words it's just another extension of as
you said waste of beautiful math so far
i've heard you say
it's a waste of beautiful math if string
theory is wrong i've said carl sagan
said
it's a waste of the space in the
universe in our galaxy
if there are no other intelligent
technological life forms
yeah and then three if they uh if the
universe is
yeah go ahead well the the difference in
those things is
there's no obligation nature has an
obligation to to make the universe
you know accessible or follow our reason
but you could say that about god too
right you could say god doesn't have to
make sense to peter and brian right well
the first thing is um we we can do
something about the fact that we're
wasting a lot of good
good math we can't do something about
the fact that we've wasted a lot of good
space
you know and even that that concept
itself is uh
uh anthropogenic or uh it's a
human-centered concept that i don't
think it's
i don't think that it has any it does
any work it does any weight i so
here's part of the problem brian i think
that people are trying to impose
rational structures of thought through
language on problems
that don't necessarily have convenient
answers or explanations right and so
people are both making claims and i see
this in philosophy a lot people become
i think it's a combination of becoming
hoodwinked by language
like the um you know even the word the
word regress
itself um is a problem peter kline the
philosopher says that
infinite regress as opposed to infinite
series you know people come
become hoodwinked by these words uh more
contemporary examples
diversity equity inclusion safe spaces
etc
and you know the the
the power of words um
it just um people are befuddled by that
but i'll give you
something else just because you put a a
question word i wrote about this in my
first book
a manual for creating atheist just just
because you put a question word in front
of a bunch of other words
it doesn't make it a legitimate sentence
and i think people have are asking
questions
about things that just it's just they're
just features there just
is you know and you see this in
christian apologetics a lot you know
when
right um you know william lane craig or
what have you
they impose questions and then they look
to
modern day sciences like you know
lincoln or have you the big bang
um and i think that the problem is that
we're both hoodwinked by language
and we're trying to analyze we're trying
to use
reason when what we should be trying to
do is
test hypotheses and make evidence of
course if you if you say that if you
make that claim
then people accuse you of scientism
i mean right where does the value yes
exactly actually debated
uh yeah let's go ahead
go ahead go ahead go ahead no no you go
okay i'll i'll start yeah um so to
address that point
head on i actually had this conversation
with
uh a difficult in a difficult scenario
which is with uh ben shapiro
who you may or may not know um and so uh
he had on william lane craig
who i always confuses it william craig
lane craig william craig lane anyway
the guy's got a lot of names uh but
typically the issue i have with him and
people like
him is that this will be the following
argument
everything that began had to have a
beginning
and everything that began and began had
a beginning was
begun and that beginning we call the
first mover
that is the column cosmological argument
correct that's
that there had to be a beginning uh for
anything that that begun
and then i said and but let me keep
going and then he said and then i say
that my second problem is that
once it begins there's a teleological
implica
implication that there was some purpose
you know it wasn't random if there isn't
all part
so then you get the notion of a personal
god and the personal god
goes from that to jesus christ now i am
a practicing uh
jew i'm not orthodox like ben shapiro
but i'm a practicing jew
and i can see tons of holes in the first
two statements
but certainly the third statement is
kind of anathema to me i mean
i believe the best thing as ely wiesel
said when the when jesus christ comes
back or the messiah comes back
uh and we're speaking on good friday by
the way so i'm wishing everybody a good
friday and a happy easter
but nevertheless if jesus does come back
we all we have to do according to elie
wiesel is ask him is this your first
time
here or your second time here and then
and then we'll know
for sure that was his falsifiable that
was his disconfirming
uh postulate the great nobel prize
winner ellie wiesel
but so peter you know for me it troubles
me because i don't accept
jesus except that he existed the
historicity of jesus is not without uh
is is without doubt that he existed we
as jews have meticulous records
in the talmud going back 2 000 years
exactly
we know not only who he was where he
lived who his rabbi was who that rabbi's
rabbi was it
so he's very well documented who jesus
was and
i don't have doubt about that the
question is as to his messianic
character
so anyway my feeling is that once you
have this
you know and i might agree with with um
with somebody like william lane craig
that if there is a beginning but what if
there's not a beginning
a beginning so how do you deal with
those kinds of statements that
yeah so go ahead yeah so that's correct
so just as a few points of contact if
your
listeners want to look out check out
again our friend kraus has come up in
the conversation
his debate with craig in australia uh
one of the things he says is you answer
these questions through science and
physics
not through make-believe uh not not
through religious questions
and if you want to see a summary of
craig's argument check out his debut
that's helpful though peter sorry to
sorry to pause but
do you think it's helpful to say like oh
it's make-believe like i mean i could
say string theories make believe too but
i mean is that a helpful tactic i mean
according to your book it's not right it
depends to say that you're full of
make-believe well it depends what you
mean by helpful right
if sometimes people will say something
is not helpful if you're speaking too
bluntly and too clearly about facts and
evidence
and so look if i told you that i know my
that my solution to
to how the universe got here is to ask
my cat and you say to me well let's just
make believe
i mean there there are certain there we
have do we have to draw the line we have
to have some criteria that we invoke for
when something is just so
so silly we don't take it seriously but
again if people make those arguments
um so just go back real quick so the
debate with alex rosenberg
craig lays those out in premise premise
conclusion i think seven
seven um conclusions that people if they
wanted more information
and then the kraus debate so i think
that we need to call things out for what
they are
and there's a difference in calling
something out in a public debate and in
a personal conversation
right and so the debate the idea is to
win
the personal conversation it can be any
one of a number of things
in a personal conversation i would not
do that
do you think that debates are pointless
in some sense like i
i can't imagine the debates in 2020
where someone's like i'm really going to
vote for biden and then all of a sudden
there's some brilliant point scored by
trump and oh i changed my mind like what
fraction
of people tuning in converted their
opinions
yeah so i've had i've had a change of
mind about that i don't
really like debates myself i strongly
prefer conversations
because with debates you're wedded to
not changing your mind
to not revising your belief and if the
goal is truth
and and what are we going to debate now
2400 years later for example debating
the existence of god so
i think debates play their role play a
role because they force
they force people to sharpen their
arguments and make them crisper and even
more accessible to people
but i think that the the the older i get
the more i realize that it's
conversation and that it's it's the idea
that we should be engaging in you know
the philosophers says mutual
understanding right so so we want to
communicate to understand with not the
truth and if we can do that the problem
is that
there are so many impediments to
thinking clearly about issues there's
you know i mentioned one being
hoodwinked by words
sentences we haven't even begun to talk
about disinformation and what have you
and i think superstition plays a big a
big role in that as well
academic superstition and now we have a
whole host of
the segway i don't know we have a whole
host of new problems with ideological
um infiltration of major systems in
american universities and
and american institutions so it's a
problem to think clearly but the core
if there were such a thing as a unified
uh theory of rationality i would argue
that
the ability and willingness to revise
one's belief is at the core of that
okay so now i want to do more
live-action role-playing so i am here at
the university of california san diego
and uh we have our physics department is
named after
one of the four women in human history
to win the nobel prize in physics and
her name is maria geppert mayer
and she was denied even an academic post
at chicago at johns hopkins and she only
got a position
here you know really relative because
her husband was also a physicist and
they hired both of them
and they could say well she's kind of
working with him and then three years
after hiring her
she won the nobel prize but before that
there was uh nobel prizes only
nobel prize given to a woman was marie
curie and around that same time
i hear a lot of of conjecture from
people like heather mcdonald who has
been on the podcast
oh come on you don't think that
scientists you know still today are
sexist
and i say i said to her um well heather
do you think that um
science is time translation invariant in
other words
like to do good science we we think of
signs as a meritocracy
and so do you think the best people were
doing science back in the early 1900s
and she said yes of course
and and i said do you think they're
still doing the best science now even
yes there's other kind of confounding
sociological things that we'll talk
about later
she said yeah the best science people
are doing science however you know it's
not you can't seriously claim that ucsd
is as
you know sexist as it was back or not
ucsd but universe chicago which didn't
give her a job
uh and you i said well you know there
was this guy einstein
and he was uh he was forbidden to win
the nobel prize because he was a jew
they actually had you know discussions
in the nobel swedish royal academy of
sciences
that einstein must not ever be allowed
to to win the nobel prize
because he trafficked in what's known as
jewish physics and jewish physics was in
contra distinction to aryan physics
which is superior
and it's experimental and einstein was a
theoretician a stereotypical jew you
know with a pencil
uh and not doing real man's physique um
do we think that
nowadays is any different than a hundred
years ago and you know in
other words why shouldn't somebody who
you know uh my africa i'm a member of
the national society of black physicist
it turns out
and and oftentimes we hear a lot in
there there have been no
african-americans to win the nobel prize
in physics
and they've done tremendous when
african-americans do tremendous work so
is it possible that science has always
been kind of like
filled with some level of this or is it
a is it an impossible question to even
ask why would you think that the problem
would be with science as opposed to the
attitudes and structures of
individuals and institutions
so we're told now that journals and
physics departments are filled with
what's called systemic racism correct in
other words the system itself
is structured maybe from its core maybe
from its founding and that's why i'm
asking you
if physics is time translation invariant
then why shouldn't
an african-american physicist snub for a
nobel prize
in all of his why shouldn't they be as
suspicious as einstein would have been
in 1920
you know the year before he won the
nobel prize so if there is systemic
racism it's incumbent upon
all of us to look at the systems where
it's found
and fix them right not just to vaguely
claim that there's some kind of problem
and then try to fix it on the back end
with the quality of outcome
but to actually identify where the
structural barrier is and fix
it and so i would ask you where where is
the structural barrier that's
the first question the second question i
have is
the same argument that you made now our
point i have another point after this if
you don't mind uh
the second point is this is exactly
what's happening now in the academies
with
i don't know if you've heard of research
justice where you
cite you privilege the citations of
people from historically marginalized
groups
and you you downplay or not at all the
citations of white cis hetero men and so
i'm going to throw that out for you to
ponder and then third thing is
i think that the problem when thinking
about these things
is that it causes a crisis of legitimacy
in the system
because you want to make sure that there
it's a meritocracy
but the way to achieve a meritocracy is
to make sure that people have equal
opportunities
it's not to you know jerry-rigged the
outcomes on the way
on the way out so we need to be honest
and ask ourselves about
these questions and i'm sure you'll
agree they're multivariate they deal
with you know i just saw something today
about number of hours
asian study i do think to be absolutely
crystal clear with you brian that there
is systemic racism
in higher ed in particular in k-12 and
that's against asians
and i think that if anybody says that
that's not true i would uh invite you
and we can i can post the links the
mountain of evidence supporting this and
even the
the legal cases that have gone through
and so i think it's a very very
complicated problem but the way to
address the problem
is is through equality of opportunity
right it's providing people with the
best possible options yeah and i look at
you
yeah and locate locating the races and i
look at you and and the work that you've
done
yeah sorry go ahead yeah go ahead
no no you go no i was just gonna say i
look at you and and the work that you've
done
and and the work that you've done um you
know i see you as someone who's
vehemently
opposed to bigotry and to and to you
know racism and all its forms like i
always say
i i hate bullies you know i i you know i
work out
i do uh martial arts i know how to use
you know different different types of
weapon
yeah i hate bullies i i used to beat the
crap out of bullies as a kid
and i know that you have that same
attitude that like you are fearless you
have courage
i hate it when someone says you know the
if i see someone who's a racist
i'm going to kill that i want to beat
that person up i'm not gonna say i'm
gonna kill the person but
but i feel this bitter sense of
hostility because
it's ultimately a sense of the ultimate
form of bigotry which could turn on me
at any moment right as a jew as a
you know uh living in in you know
society although i i
think america is the best place that
jews have ever lived you know with the
possible exception of israel
uh today but anyway uh but getting back
to like specifically but then i'm told
that
that um you know academia is rife with
racism
and then yet i ask all my colleagues and
they're very brave people too peter and
they say to me
i'm not a racist and so i just don't
understand how
a system comprised of individuals you
know it's like the atomic hypothesis
versus the monad hypothesis
how is it possible that that no
physicist will admit
being racist but yet the system is built
uh uh
you know has definitely exhibits racism
so so what is it is it that we're trying
to rid something
of an effect like we'll never rid the
world of anti-semitism as much as i
would love to do that
it's just you know the world is made of
flawed fallen individuals okay so
there's a lot to unpack you said a lot
of stuff there
so upon critical race theory the
ordinary everyday state of affairs
is racism and so every disparity is
is understood like that and if you read
helen pluck rose and james lindsay's
cynical theories
they talk about a conspiracy this is a
vast conspiracy without any conspirators
the problem is that when people want to
make claims that the very tools of
reason
scientific analysis epistemic adequacy
etc
that those things are the white man's
tools those things are
products of the the patriarchy and you
can't use those
to disassemble the racist structure that
we have now you need to use as something
else and so
when you take those tools of analysis
away from us
which is interesting because when you
take those tools of analysis away
you can't prove what you want to prove
so you have to make up your own
epistemology
i i want to i want to say something so
my my mentor
um was was um interned in buchenwald
as he told me his parents were were
jewish and uh he went back his name is
frank wesley his
uh and then he liberated it too well how
did you know that
did you know him did you know frank how
did i i listened to the audiobook all
the way to the
oh wow all right cool i knew it from the
uh
audiobook i do my research oh wow i'm
very impressed by that
um but one thing that was really
interesting when he went back and
liberated the concentration camps
he advocated that i mean that's the gold
standard for bad right i mean that's
gold standard he protected the guards
many of whom were vicious to him he
protected the people who
showed incredible cruelty to him and
i i think that there's there's some
inconceivable decency in that there's
something so
lovely and so human about that
but what we have today is
something else something that if you
disagree with someone you're a nazi or
you're a bigot or you're a racist and
you're a homophobe
and we've created a very dangerous
situation that's buttressed by a number
of things right now
one of those things is that what's
coming out of the university
is unbelievably dangerous hurtful
harmful and divisive
and it needs to stop and i don't see any
any uh i don't think it's sustainable
specifically with regard to critical
race theory and you know seeing color
and a lot of the prop
a lot of these propositions so you know
you you said a lot there from
anti-semitism to to to violence to
how do we we address these problems
yeah no i i do tend to ramble but i i
have an ultimate goal in mind a path i'm
going to i'm just reminding folks here
on the into the impossible podcast
on clubhouse and eventually on youtube
we have
uh collections of billionaires brainiacs
uh thought leaders athletes we have
really
a panoply of of brilliant minds that
make up the multiverse of
intellectualism
i'm trying to assemble peter the
university i wish i went to
the university i wish i could teach at
and i do so remotely i've had nine nobel
prize winners on four billionaires
and thought leaders professors all
around the world including uh the
current president of the
american physical society who's a mentor
to me his name is sylvester james gates
jim gates one of the fathers of super
symmetry and string theory he happens to
be african-american
and he does not uh deny the the
struggles of the african-american but he
says it's undeniably equally so
that the uh academia and physics in
particular
has gotten in immeasurably better
throughout his career now he's in his
late 60s early 70s
uh but he said there the arc is is
bending towards towards progress towards
justice
and i just wonder sometimes i feel like
i'm the victim of and you and i might be
victims of
because of our aid of the generation
that came before us the generation
of the feynmans who would like hit on
their grad students that were females or
the undergraduates that they would come
into
they were rampant sexist and you know
this is not taking away in revisionist
history it's just a known fact he was a
known womanizer
etc so uh because of that because of his
uh his awful treatment of women and you
know if he treated my daughters like
that i'd feed him and
punch him in the nose right but but the
point is i shouldn't have to do that it
should
but i shouldn't be blamed for it either
and i feel like as we're coming up on
easter
again i used to be an altar boy in the
catholic church that's a story for
another day but i'm born biologically
jewish i do want to wish people
a happy easter and a good friday and i'm
glad people are joining you and me
but i read your book and i think about
your work and the controversies
in your life and i say where is their
redemption in the world where is there a
chance
to redeem not only us like currently
like you admit to mistakes that led you
to write this book
that you were a boorish person at some
conversations with people that you had
that you should have treated better and
the book is atonement
it's a form of what we jews called
teshuva is that gone
is that over are we ever able to to undo
not only what we did personally but if
we can't even undo what we did
personally how can we atone for the sins
of the fine men's you know womanizing
behavior of the past is that even
possible
yeah i guess it's not possible if you
live in a klingon society
uh and i from listening to your podcast
i i know you're a star trek fan
um i think of course it's possible not
only is redemption always possible
but the idea that we can this is why
reason and evidence is so important
right
because if you have one piece of data
that comes in
that's factually incorrect then you will
create
a world outside of yourself that that
leads you to think that you're bringing
about your flourishing but you're not
that's because you have incorrect
information
so just an example of that i've been
toying with these you know i love
questions asking people specific
questions to
to figure out what you know what they
actually believe and how that lends
itself to their ideology
so one question i've been toying with is
how many
uh unarmed african americans were killed
by the police in 2019
and from that question it's a kind of
it's 25 or 30.
well it's under 20. it depends nice
between 7 and 19 basically but the
but when i asked my neighbors that they
said 20 000.
which is an absolutely astonishing
figure but if if i thought that there
were 20 000 people being
black unarmed black men being murdered
by the the police of course you need to
know the number of white people too say
the number of white people was 15.
you know i might be rioting in the
streets and trying to rip down the
civilization as well i mean that that's
that's basically a holocaust but i think
that
it's so important epistle
epistemological hygiene is important but
we don't talk about it
you know we we talk about dental hygiene
etc i told my dad that when he was alive
that i think we should teach people
epistemological hygiene and my dad said
why don't we why don't we focus instead
on teaching them how to read
um but but i i do think that there's
something
in um teaching people what to value
so the older i get and the more i throw
myself at these issues
i've realized that most questions are
moral questions that masquerade as
epistemological questions
so people will hold their views on the
basis of
um something moral like their
self-identity they want to be a good
person and what what have you
and so that's why providing them with
evidence doesn't work
unless the subject in question has no
moral valence
so you're the exploring the identity
between what it means to be a good
person
and the belief is crucial in all of
these things
and so to bring it back what you're
saying there's always an opportunity for
human decency there's always a hot
opportunity for compassion but
we have to make sure that the tools are
in place to get us there
and one of those tools is conversation
right right
one of those tools i would argue is i
personally democracy
yeah go ahead
i would say you know and this is where
you and i might differ
yeah i would say one of those tools is
religion and and i don't even mean it
has to be
you know uh my abrahamic religion that i
practice
um but that the the culture of
redemption
the philosophical import of
self-betterment
of conversation uh of course there are
many many
negative things that that religion has
done but we're i'm seeing now you know
this article by phil zuckerman
in today's los angeles times about how
it's good news that
societal belief in god is declining and
i remember
um you know many times having
conversations with freeman dyson
and others who were self-proclaimed
agnostics as i really call myself a
devout practicing agnostic
and i'll get into what that means if
you're interested but but for me
um the the virtues of religion in
community etc
are very hard to replicate they're very
durable
people do things i've spoken at places
called the sunday assembly
there's many of them around the world i
love them they're my brothers and
sisters they just happen to be not
that happen to be secular i've spoken at
the ethical humanist society the oldest
one in the world in in chicago
uh i have no problem doing that i love
talking it's respectful but what do they
do
have you ever been to a sunday assembly
peter yeah yes
so what do they do there in oregon might
be the same as here in california what
they do is they start off with a hymn
and that hymn is you know usually uh
peter paul and mary or you know whatever
uh you know couple of jews right but
anyway uh then they then they have
uh they have a a reading you know
instead of from the torah it's from uh
philip roth
or whatever and then they get into a
reading and some some scripture and then
they have a charity
you know which we call siddhaka and
judaism and they're basically
replicating the structure of an
organized religion
and i don't have any i don't have to say
oh you have to invent that no
but um but i wonder like do we have
uh acrimony where we are actually very
similar
because i don't think the people that
are not believing in god are going to
sunday assembly or the ethical humanist
i think they're staying home and
watching the nba yeah but
you don't need that but but now you know
it's impossible for politics not to
enter every single aspect of life
and we do need a safe space i argue
where we think about the big questions
of
you know cosmology and metaphysics and
meaning but but what do you say that you
know
one of the tools you say is conversation
i say it's religion
as bill o'reilly would say prove me
wrong right
so full disclosure phil zuckerman is a
is a friend of mine
um i read his books yeah yeah so the the
question is
uh it's we've turned up the substitution
hypothesis
and the substitution hypothesis is the
basic basically
do people need some kind of religiosity
do they need some kind of belief
and i don't mean a formal structure of
belief or any abrahamic tradition or
what have you
and clay rutledge has done some good
work on this the idea is that as
a belief in traditional abrahamic face
has fallen
other things super other superstitions
have gone in to replace that
and so i will make a full disclosure
from somebody who is deeply involved in
the
new atheist movement at every level and
say that
i did have a pollyanna view and i did
believe that if we could just
eliminate this superstition that was
holding down humanity
then that would give an opportunity for
reason rationality and discourse to
thrive
i did not foresee the
um the metastatization of the new
dominant moral orthodoxy that has no
redemption narrative in which
that but that uses some of the same
mechanisms i published a piece many many
years ago about privileges the original
sin
you know political correctness is
blasphemy so that
prevent the ideas from being dislodged
so if that is the natural state of
affairs then shouldn't we
seek the one that leads to the greatest
human flourishing
and if that's the case then by what
criteria do we do we invoke and
and would it be christianity would it be
judaism or
uh would it be hinduism or something
else that we haven't of course
the the other thing is could we don't
know maybe you need a super intelligent
ai
to give us what those rules are so that
there are objective rules but we
we just don't have the cognitive
capacity to figure this out but i think
that the larger point
is that um
i personally believe and my bet is that
you believe this as well
is that um morals are rationally
derivable so you can
we can there are reasons for why we
should be decent to people
and why we should be compassionate and
why we should for example why we should
value
equality of opportunity and give
everyone a public education of the first
rate as john rawls says for example
my my problem is that anything that
would interfere in that like the
original example we used with galileo
and the pope anything that would would
privilege on one side
de facto out of the gate that's why i
asked you know what would you do if the
two things
were in conflict on which side would you
air and that's also you just had them on
your podcast eric weinstein
that's his his question about gender
studies if there's a
conflict between biology and gender
studies on which side do you air
and so we see the a very very pernicious
very dangerous very divisive dominant
more orthodoxy now and the question that
i have from my
my friends who are still deeply involved
in the new atheist movement
is were we better off under christianity
or were we better are we better off in
the current situation now
right i mean even just think of that one
thing first peter 3 15
giving evidence for the the beliefs you
have you know giving a reason for the
beliefs you hold
that itself is an anathema to this to
this orthodoxy you know
i hope i didn't talk too much right and
i see that you know i've had
conversation with michael charmer
with michael shermer and i have a
lawrence crosses coming up
but the you know i want to turn the
tables on you uh you know
the student becomes the teacher how
could you be wrong about god
in other words let me just say how could
you be wrong about religion
first yeah could you be wrong about god
do you admit there could be evidence
that could persuade you and if so what
is it
and i'd like to explore that uh from a
physicist's point of view
yeah i'd be happy to to uh uh explain
i've actually had that conversation with
sean who's a very good very close friend
of mine so
in in order to answer the question um
i'll ask your permission if this is okay
i'd like to explore the opposite
question
and that is what is not sufficient
evidence to to
uh um warrant belief in god okay so
let's start
start with dad sure that's okay with you
sure so it's not a dodge for the
question in other words i'm going to get
back to i think it's a helpful heuristic
to think about it
so what is not sufficient evidence no
um let me turn down the the brightness
on my screen before it kills me here
there we go um so no physical phenomenon
would do the trick
right no physical phenomena
no um um
and this is this is the you really have
to think about this
kraus says you know what if you walk
outside
and you look at the stars and it says i
am god believe in me and you haven't
been doing lsd or
any drugs or you haven't been drinking
and everybody sees it in their own
language
to me that would be insufficient to to
warrant that belief
when when i said that actually he guest
lectured at my my class at portland
he said um well i know something you
don't know
and i love it when people tell me that
because i want to know it too
and i said well what do you know and um
he said that the total the aggregate
amount of energy in the universe
would be to be able to do that would be
just
you would need something outside the
universe it would cost take more energy
to do that
i'll defer to your expertise in that and
i told him
uh which he later agreed to that's not
sufficient evidence to warrant belief in
god because you couldn't rule out
alternative
possibilities like time travelers
trickster alien cultures
interdimensional i mean so that that
wouldn't be enough
so when i asked dawkins that question i
think in our second public conversation
he said and this is this is um this is
all
christian apologists are also very
familiar with this this is why they
don't
the best christian apologists don't
defer to evidence they
reason you know dawkins said if there
was something a hidden message in pie
or if there was something um
something that you could reason to so it
wouldn't be
um so kind of like a kalam argument it
certainly wouldn't be fine
tuning it wouldn't be anything
evidential it'd have to be based in
reason
so the answer to your question then now
we know what wouldn't constitute
sufficient evidence for me to change my
mind and i also think at this point
what a definition of atheist is so i am
an atheist
and i define atheists so we can move
forward in the conversation as
i do not think there's sufficient
evidence to warrant belief in god
but if i were given that evidence i
would change my mind
and that evidence is again that's the
disconfirmation question that i started
with the pope
so the older i get the more important i
realize it is when you have a
conversation with someone immediately
start with the disconfirmation criteria
boom so that's what it would take right
yeah that's what it would take
and and we have no evidence of that
right well here's so i'm gonna you know
indulge uh beg your
indulgence and your forbearance as pope
uh pope peter
uh and uh here's here's one thing i like
again i am a what i consider a devout
practicing
agnostic meaning that my friend freeman
dyson the late great freeman dyson
and martin reese lord martin reece he
they say things like they're agnostic
but then i asked them peter i say well
um you know what church do you go to and
they say oh i don't go to church
and i say well imagine a super
intelligent alien looking at you
and looking at richard dawkins who is an
atheist a militant self-proclaimed
atheist or lawrence krauss
and they would say here's freeman dyson
or martin reese and here's
uh and here's uh richard dawkins well
they both don't go to the same church
you know in other words there's nothing
practical that distinguishes
the most people that call themselves
agnostic i think is a cop-out
and i'm speaking as an agnostic but i'm
speaking as a devout
yeah yeah i could i couldn't agree more
and the next thing i want to say
relates to can i just put a pin in that
real quick because i think what you said
is
is that more important yeah yeah go for
it go for it yeah so
you and i don't yeah go ahead we don't
and i'm gonna say that you believe this
i'm gonna
uh um i rarely do this but i'm gonna be
safe in this
you and i don't believe in the easter
bunny right we don't believe this is a
big east we don't believe in the tooth
fairy
so we're not tooth fairy agnostics we're
tooth fairy atheists
and i think saying that you're agnostic
is a crop out and often people use it so
they don't want to seem as
like they're an extremist they don't
want to hurt people's feelings
so i i couldn't agree more i think it
has no business in our lexicon
even even on that and in my uh and my
thank you yeah
yeah go ahead well okay
i was gonna say i'll let you know on
sunday yeah well i'll just i'll finish
the thought so even to you you would
even need to get
you wouldn't even even need on a scale
from one to ten right in the book i talk
about how to have impossible
conversation skills
you even to get to a five you would need
evidence
so even to say maybe well maybe i'm an
agnostic well
okay so what evidence did you get to
make you eggnog well there is no
evidence
so you so so you're not an agnostic
right right right and and equally so so
it's funny peter because everything you
say
uh first of all i want to commend you on
the book i read the book by chris voss
um never split the difference and i
didn't find that as
as helpful you know when i'm having an
argument with my wife and i'm like
no deal you know like sorry honey it's
over my way
i'm never splitting the difference with
you thanks to chris who might be
listening i don't know he's on clubhouse
a lot that guy
and i love that book too but uh but
you're much more practical yours is much
more
uh you know his is practical for hostage
negotiators and you know
ceo uh you know titans of the of the uh
negotiating world but but anyway yours
is much more practical
interpersonal introspective and i do
love that book uh how to have impossible
conversations today's guest in the
impossible podcast peter bogosian
professor at portland state university
author of
of uh this wonderful book with james
lindsey uh who is known as conceptual
james
on twitter and elsewhere we'll get to
twitter hopefully a little bit and
clubhouse
i'm not gonna leave clubhouse out
there's some impossible conversations
that we need to have about clubhouse
uh but we and with the guests on
clubhouse the folks that are in the room
there's about 90 plus people there
now we're looking forward to talking to
you in a few minutes taking your
questions and comments but i
as the host of the into the impossible
podcast on youtube dr brian keating on
itunes everywhere else
uh i do want to explore this a little
bit more because one thing that speaks
to me about judaism and i have
as i said i was an altar boy in the
catholic church i was
a i was born biologically jewish i came
back to it later in my life i
taught myself to read hebrew and aramaic
and and study it in great depth
i find you know now i'm gonna attack my
friend lawrence krauss or
your our our friend lawrence krauss and
richard dawkins because
oftentimes it's incredibly sophistic in
the sense that
the essence of what they're looking for
is scientific evidence for example avi
loeb
who i've had on my show he's got the
number one book called uh
extraterrestrial about this object
yeah so that's a wonderful book and i
had a great conversation with him
and um and nevertheless we had uh
we had to debate this this issue of
whether or not
uh you know what would constitute proof
that this really came from an
extraterrestrial civilization
and and he said well we just have to
wait a couple of years
for and more objects to be discovered
with this brand new telescope called the
ruben observatory
i said avi if i believed that this was
my one chance to prove the one known
example of extraterrestrial
intelligence i would not wait a minute
i would tell my friend yuri milner the
ultra russian billionaire
i would say scrap these plans to send
cell phone cameras to proxima centauri
no instead let's send a cubesat to
omumua before it gets past the
heliopause and is completely out of
reach and he said no no no we don't need
to do that
i said avi i'm not sure you really
believe what you're saying and then
he went on to talk about his israeli um
you know which uh i remind my friends
of uh of the israeli persuasion that
their nickname is the sabra and the
sabra is a cactus
that's very spiky on the outside and
very uh squishy on the inside
uh but avi he said things like well you
know we really
could have resolved if god really wanted
to prove himself
to abraham he could have just advanced
the technology of the iphone
and given him an iphone back then uh on
the mountaintop when he was sacrificing
isaac
and i said that's so ludicrous it's like
completely ludicrous and it's ludicrous
even in the context
of the bible itself so one reason that i
think the bible has wisdom and not
knowledge and
two different two separate things to me
and much more important to have wisdom
than knowledge i'll get into that some
other time but the bible says
at 40 days after the jews and i'm
speaking as a jew we're supposed to be
smart you know we have 30
uh over-representation of nobel
laureates right people think of jews as
smart
but these smart jews supposedly 40 days
after scene
we should put a pin up i would love to
talk about that we might need a part two
by the way
yeah do you know that that yeah because
i know that people like eric
weinstein and others do you know that's
only ashkenazi jews from a certain
region the region around
breslau uh yes but yes i always say
yeah yeah i always say god is a sense of
humor because
he gave us the nobel prize but he also
he also gave us all the ashkenazi jew
diseases
like tay sachs and crohn's disease uh
anyway so let me get back to this uh so
after the miracles
uh led to led to the passover miracles
that we're celebrating right now
uh hogsmeade to all my jewish listeners
out there but um but where 40 days after
witnessing this
the jews build a golden calf in other
words the bible is saying
don't expect scientific evidence because
even if you get the most
powerful scientific evidence that you
could ever see mass witnessing of a
supernatural event
40 days later you're going to make a god
out of gold and you're going to worship
it and i do agree with you
people seem to need a religion nowadays
it might be
socialism or wokism or whatever you want
to call it or it might be
it might be the green movement or it
might be secularism
and in my field it's noblism people
worship the nobel prize
and the people be that win it and and
the committee that elects it
almost almost unparalleled as a monopoly
anyway i've been talking so if you want
to respond to any of this yeah i do and
let me know if you
think that this response i like one of
the reasons i like speaking to you is
because you're very sincere and you're
very clear and there's absolutely no
obfuscation whatsoever and i
always appreciate that so thank you so
the difference is
yeah the difference is dawkins in
particular
and uh dennett myself and others we are
taking
uh aim at people who make objective
claims and so
there was a man who walked on water
right that's an objective claim about
the nature of reality
muhammad flew to heaven on a winged
horse you know someone reincarnates
through
through time and bodies there's a happy
hunting ground all of these things are
objective claims
and what we are targeting is there is
insufficient evidence to warrant belief
in these objective claims now
those objective claims ground the moral
claims right so you
you the whole idea of you know and what
you said about the
bible having wisdom but not knowledge
that's again the subject of another
podcast
but we can we can take
a step back and look at if the
and look at this one of the reasons that
people believe
that the the moral edicts of the bible
are true it's because
they're they are accompanied by
metaphysical morals so dawkins myself
and others
are just saying we do not think that
there is sufficient evidence to warrant
belief
uh in these phenomenon and in the god
delusion dawkins
on a the dawkins scale of one to seven
he says he's a six
of one being absolute belief seven being
disbelief later he calibrated that up to
6.9
i'm probably like a 6.9 myself so
i think that occupying a one or a seven
is is a mistake it's not just an
epistemological mistake but it's a very
dangerous mistake to make
so the bottom line in all of that is
we're taking
um the problem is that people are making
objective claims
and then those objective claims are
informing public policy
um and i want to just go to that next
because next week i have a video coming
out from prager university which will
turn off a lot of people but uh that's
okay
i do videos with noam chomsky and
lawrence tribe and i do videos with
dennis prager and ben shapiro
uh but this video is called uh trust
the science or um the scientific method
and it's about the statement that we get
that we must
trust the science or listen to science
and trust scientists
and i rail against that as a scientist
because i think the secret coded
messages
obey scientists that we are actually
commanded now
not just to listen to science but
because science is opaque
it's obfuscated it's specialized
activities done by special individuals
using special technologies and no more
would i go down to the
to the health sciences facility here at
ucsd and poke my head around the cat
scan machine
i don't have access to that technology i
don't know how to use it so
so too should people not question
science because it's not really for us
yeah my taxes paid for it but
but no we must obey and i have a great
deal of problem with that even as a
scientist
right because i don't think we've earned
the right to be politicians that's why
we elected joe biden right to
he we didn't elect you know anthony
fauci we elected joe biden
and so the problem with obeying science
and and this notion that there is one
party of science
and there's one party of ignoramuses um
i wonder you know is that message
a good one for society like ours with
nuclear weapons and
and a powerful is that a dangerous you
know scenario to be in where we
basically have rule by unelected uh
dictators called scientists
well that's a great question i part of
that is if we had a system that was
so we're in the middle of a legitimacy
crisis right now right so we
we have and we had mentioned this before
about black physicists etc
so i don't know i don't know if i should
take this question in terms of
legitimacy and other take the question
in terms of obey i personally don't see
the problem
you're articulating a concern which is
so far from
reality that i don't see that it's even
with all due respect
i don't even understand why you're
bringing it up i mean we have a populist
that
does not respect the science does not i
mean what's jerry coyne
and uh why evolution is true and then
faith versus fact he puts
his evolutionary biologist you know
roughly the statistics or half of
americans don't
either don't accept the facts of
evolution notice i didn't say believe in
evolution but accept the facts of
evolution
and think that the world the humans
existed in their present form ten
thousand years
and then you can look at the the
attitudes about anthropogenic global
warming
you can look at and again i'm not taking
a side in that fight you know i
matt ridley is a the rational optimist
is uh
he has some really good stuff but i i
think that the the key of this whole
thing is i don't understand
why to me that's not a concern at all
that people
that people are trusting science too
much to me i think we have exactly the
opposite problem
very good very interesting and actually
it's not only unique to america i
remember giving a talk
in galileo's hometown of archetree italy
outside of florence
and i showed a slide uh kind of mocking
american understanding of science and it
said
uh one in four americans think the sun
goes around the earth
and everyone knows stupid american
i don't know why i always get like a
russian accent or whatever but then i
showed the next slide peter and it was
33 percent of europeans believe that to
be true
so it's not unique to us and uh and i
and i do feel like
that is we live in an unprecedented
technological age at which we have
access
you know to to mass technology like
twitter like clubhouse
and actually speaking of clubhouse i
should turn to that now because peter i
have a
i have a scientific you know you think
of astronomers
that we're always on telescopes but
we're actually always on telecons
and not telescopes unfortunately so i
have a telecon in 20 minutes and i want
to get
questions and answers uh from our
clubhouse friends yeah so
um maybe i'm just gonna ask you one more
question just for me yeah
we'll end this video interview this will
be a part one we'll do a part two soon
i'd love to do this with you peter i'd
love to have a conversation with you and
me
and stephen meyer who is not like
william craig and a very different kind
of approach i don't know if you've ever
met him he lives
up in your corner of the planet but um
we could talk about that some other time
he was just on my podcast this this past
week
i want to ask you the last thing um
which is about uh kind of the the
uh the notion that you talk about very
different
in contra distinction to vos you end the
words with an imprecation
you say be like water what does that
mean to you what does it mean to be like
water when the stakes are so high
in some conversations i feel abortion is
murder i think gun control
i think the vaccine is bill gate
i don't really believe that by the way
but uh but how can you be like water i
mean
you know why should why should i be like
water this should be like fire so can
you explain that philosophy which is so
unique and
and commendable but i would like you to
flush it out right i have
trouble being like water in certain
circumstances as well
i think if you start you know socrates
said wisdom begins in wonder
i think if you start with a genuine
curiosity about why people believe what
they do
in the theaters socrates says
plato was the plato wrote socrates a
character in the dialogues
socrates says that people only believe
what they do
because of the information they have and
if everybody had perfect information you
used the word perfect before when you
were
speaking about the pope pope if everyone
had perfect information they'd come to
the same conclusion about something
and so every time you create
an administrative relationship or a
defensive posture in someone
you're less likely to help them revise
their belief
but what's even more important is that
you're less likely to revise your own
belief
and if you want to be someone who
believes true things that's absolutely
essential
and so you know just um
reading something today about um
german interrogators who are very kind
something that's very common in in the
interrogation realm to be particularly
kind to your
subjects because they're more likely to
reveal information than if you're
if you're nasty to them all right i'd
like to
perhaps um right um and end with a story
about
that my mentor taught me about chickens
oh it was in the book did i take was
that in the book about the chickens
so he was telling me this this story he
put a um
a caller was this in the book yeah a
chicken
an electrical shock collar in these
seven chickens
and there's a strict pecking order of
chicken one picking chicken
picking all the other chickens chicken
two not picking chicken one
chicken seven not pick pecking anybody
and once the
the um chicken raised its head
they would give it a shock now the
question to the audience is is it
easier to turn chicken seven to chicken
one or chicken one to chicken seven
and once this is grocked you can
understand why
you should be kind to people why harsh
punishment doesn't work for prisons for
schools etc
and the idea is that it's more difficult
you can't turn chicken seven's been
had it's the [ __ ] kicked out of him his
whole life for her but
one zap or two zaps um
achieves that so i think be being like
water is
is a more uh compassionate way to deal
with um not only other people's beliefs
but your own beliefs
just get more mileage out of it you're
more likely to find well
yeah absolutely no i i do love that and
like i said i love chris voss
but uh it's not as practical on a daily
basis than not all of us negotiate
uh with the fbi hostage negotiation team
and so i think there's a lot more
practical wisdom
although you give them a lot of shout
outs uh in the book i want to end peter
uh with the video portion then we'll
switch to clubhouse only so get your
questions raise your hands on clubhouse
if you're interested in talking with me
and or peter
and i ask all my questions all my guests
who honor me by coming on the into the
impossible podcast
three questions but i'm i don't have as
much time and so we're gonna do a part
two
i'm gonna ask you just one question and
that relates to into the impossible
that's a phrase
that's sir arthur c clarke came up with
in addition to
uh two of my favorites any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic which
reminds me if you want my monday magic
emails you can subscribe at
briankeating.com and you can find peter
on twitter peter gagosian
but but arthur also said for every
expert
there's an equal and opposite expert and
the last thing he said is
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
that's the origin of the podcast name
and i want to ask you peter kind of
advice to your former self if you could
talk to 20 year old peter
and you would ask tell him one piece of
nugget of wisdom
that would give him the courage to go
into the impossible when the chips are
down
what would you advise young peter to do
oh boy i have to think about that let's
see in five seconds or less
um
i i think i think i would advise myself
to of the ancient greek virtue of
parahesia
of speaking truth in the face of danger
regardless of the consequences
of a kind of radical honesty with
yourself and others
and one of the one of the many reasons
you should do so aristotle talks about
the highest form of friendship being
between two virtuous people
you'll have genuine relationships you
won't have to fake it
you won't have to lie you won't have to
be deceitful
um people you say what you mean and
others will say what you mean
you'll know what other people mean
because you have genuine friendships
with them
any disagreement can be um adjudicated
within the context of that
so i would say don't don't be a coward
like speak but but also you have to have
one other principle and it's
it's the emerging theme in this podcast
which is you have to be willing to
revise your beliefs
and if you're willing to revise your
beliefs and you couple that with being
forthright in your speech particularly
unpopular speech then i think you really
have a recipe for a life worth living
yeah and you become an unstoppable force
once you have courage in this way
and i'd just like to add to that you
know another famous quote by feynman
who's a very complicated character he
said science
is the belief in the ignorance of
experts
meaning that if you just trusted
everything that you know isaac newton
had believed and said
uh or the pope and the uh you know
earlier than that
uh you would never have had galileo and
then galileo if you trusted everything
he said
you'd be wrong and we should even doubt
what feynman said and if you don't do
that
as feynman said you are the biggest fool
of all and it's appropriate for the day
after april fools
uh wanting to recognize that we made it
through
i want to wish everybody a good friday a
good good friday
uh happy easter if you celebrate happy
passover if you celebrate or whatever
you celebrate i wish you a happy
uh weekend and now we're gonna switch
clubhouse only i see a couple of hands
raised
peter if you want to go and get your
phone and and
take yourself off of mute or raise your
volume let's do that and for now
signing off on the video portion of the
into the impossible podcast with today's
guest
uh dr peter bogosian author along with
james lindsey
of how to have impossible conversations
what could be more appropriate
for into the impossible podcast signing
off of this particular pandemic podcast
and going to clubhouse
now